hello everybody welcome to this banter
blitz session where I'll be playing the
people I'm joined by Tony what's up man
how's it going everything okay yeah yeah
so guys remember you can challenge me
and chess funny for you go to the show's
page and then you'll find there where to
challenge me and my nickname is jose
cuenca i see that already we have like
some challenges so maybe it's time to
stop playing and whenever you have a
question feel free to ask we'll be
answering all of them so perfect what
time could be reappointed yeah three or
five minute games yeah three plus zero
or five plus zero I already got a
challenge from they commute the
commutator from Denmark you've been to
Denmark I have not
I was wondering you know where I want I
want to go to Spain first okay it's cool
you're welcome they're trying it yeah I
always wanted to go man when I walk down
the street yeah come on yeah and Spain
will we live actually in the streets you
know people are walking all the time
talking nonsense okay so he's not here
so I'll have to abort the game so let's
find another opponent if you challenge
make sure you are ready to go no longer
than five five minutes yeah no longer
five minutes we want to get as many
people as we can
exactly so it looks like so we are
playing on chest 24 today not on lately
chest so make sure you get your
challenges in a chest 24 we have some
old we have some people that being with
us all the time okay shock shock my
friend he he is he he's always
challenging people okay he was saying hi
to you all right you guys all know GM
have a queen Co Frank coin guy you get
she twinkle twinkle he's a funny wardens
management means cuff you know call me
Peppa kappa i love that and cuenca is
actually a city in Spain and also in
Ecuador
yeah okay a TTS honza how's it going my
man love it I always hear you go for the
Halloween gambit if allowed maybe maybe
in the next game
no Buchan Idol played some sort of Dutch
and then he's planning to go eat five
years so I should stop that maybe by
going b3 and Bishop beat you got two
nice bishops this Bishop on g2 is doing
a fantastic job
we should be too then bring the rooks to
the center there's a five-minute games
against L Bucanero the link it for that
link to challenge is on the chat chest
24 yeah you can challenge our GM in
residence all right
yeah it's my second time here I love st.
Louis yeah yeah you were in a Saints in
those blue shirt yeah I want to see
their ice hockey match and it was a lot
of fun to see the Blues and right let me
just okay rook t1 I visited a lot of
things this time you know I went to the
Science Museum to the History Museum
down there in the forest park I love
that Park man it's it's yeah that's one
thing I think one of the best in the
country
yeah they told me it's bigger than the
Central Park game yeah I go there every
morning like an old man like feeding the
birds and stuff like that Queen c2 maybe
it's time to go efore yeah if all looks
really nice now so I've takes you for
Queen takes e4 and then e six could be a
potential witness here so how long have
you been here working working in the
club oh man have you been keeping up in
the eye oh man yes of course
actually we one of my best friend's is
doing quite well over there Debby done
tongue okay yesterday he Biddle Enderman
from the states and he's playing in bore
number three tomorrow I think because
today they have a rest day and then he's
playing Nikita we tee off tomorrow in
born on May 3 or 4
actually so his it's got great chances
let's see what happens you know that we
worries a huge yeah you win the
tournament you you qualify for the
candidates so what do you think is gonna
we're sorry who do you think is gonna
win okay I mean Magnus is there and
Fabiano is there but the good news for
the others is that they of course they
kind of qualify for the candidates
Magnus is the current world champion and
Fabi has a spot over there
kelsey is the last challenger so it's
quite open I don't know there are a lot
of talk cam so they were over there
let's see what happens still six rounds
to go
anything could happen Oh Quincy - yeah
so it's got this Asics quickness which I
can attack like with all my pieces maybe
I can even double my books on the e-file
also this night could come to d-21 in e4
from afar it's attacking f6 actually so
it takes 8x8 takes
okay - doesn't worry me because there's
Queen b1 this Queen g7 is actually a
very interesting move because maybe he
wants to go see fine now okay still not
not so dangerous I would say science is
gonna go 8-4 here maybe I can try to go
Knight g5 putting more pressure on the
a6 pot and of course if he takes on g5 h
x g5 there could be some d5 ideas and
then this bishop is gonna be a monster
over there it's 2100 l Bucanero that's
like a brand of a beer you know it's
baby want to go away you you can also
open them the chess 24 chat where people
will be to asking some questions for
sure maybe the link click that link and
then people will be there for sure so
let's play Bishop c3 attacking the rook
maybe I can try to go Queen B - even
though I'm not so sure about this move
probably this Knight g5 idea I think his
rook has to go back to the a file I mean
bringing the room to the hh5 square
looks at
crazy alright so now 95 really like this
move so pressure on a six
he takes I just pre moving HX g5 so you
can follow both of them look a - okay
but then g6 could be a witness over
there so I'm not so sure about this move
86 I could even try to go 92 and then B
should be four or something like that
but g6 could be a witness after 86 but
definitely was an interesting trying now
I'm gonna go to Eve for so putting
pressure on this f6 Bishop he goes back
to DA Tori 7 then d5 at some point would
be could be dangerous for him not yet
because of the d5 he can close a
position with e5 but okay at the same
time this Knight and basic is doing
basically nothing it's just a stupid
night there that's nowhere to go for for
all the viewers if you heard a voice
maybe he didn't but that was the man in
the back Danny Machuca is he's actually
standing right he won't be on camera for
some reason but you know I can take a
step to the right Danny take a step to
the right say hi to everybody
[Laughter]
alright the community the commentator
says sorry oh the guy to make a movie
say sorry he thought you were not
starting yet I guess okay okay
communicate communicate or you can you
can challenge me again and then I take
your challenge give you another chance
to beat me in front of everybody to
embarrass me now f4 you know putting a
lot of pressure on the e5 phone if I
manage to take this phone will be game
over for him because this king of g8 is
extremely weak my friend el Bucanero we
should be to more pressure on e5 now
nobody is gonna save you from me taking
this point love it yeah alright pieces
you can yeah I'll take this take this
and then I could have another stripe
like Bishop d5 but okay he
stop that and now centralizing pieces
that's always a good idea
attacking b6 it's gotta go I don't know
where probably to d7 and then the okay I
can play Bishop d6 even or even Group D
- okay he can take that Bishop on e5
still is upon up upon his upon so give
me that he's got only 30 seconds so
probably he's very close to losing this
game are you playing tournaments manner
I I didn't know I have a veteran so long
not an active player okay that's why I
don't play I don't play to people that's
why I always on this side of the talking
all right
for anybody who's just joining us please
challenge GM Pepe on chess 24 the link
is up on our chat so please click the
link and our YouTube chat you get get
there and then if you do challenges no
more than Game five time control alright
game fives - want to get as many people
as in we can so typically it was like
about nine or ten people in we want to
do just that
somebody said triple your pawns must be
the worst anti positional thing in chess
depends say you know this always say you
we have always to pay attention to the
exact position you know there could be
positions where we have triple pawns and
then that could be extremely good for us
you never know okay I'm gonna take a
commutator but he didn't challenge me
commutator where are you where you at
man kappa data kata from spain yeah if
you want to play if you want to play
give us a challenge right so I'm gonna
ask you this let's let's give everybody
a look at the life of a GM how often are
you on the road how often do you travel
other year I mean may I probably out of
Spain like four five months per year
it's crazy and out of my town maybe I'm
nine months per year so yeah it's
because I mean now with this common type
of thing just 24 I trouble a lot them
and I go to Latin America a lot of times
now for example in November I will play
the national championship in Spain okay
last time I finished second so I mean
this is one of the tournaments I prefer
it's really it's really hard but then I
really enjoy it and then in November
I'll be playing in Mexico
then we're gonna appear in one movie in
Chile it's a chess movie and then yes so
we're going to Santiago de Chile to like
to film like for I don't know will be
like two three minutes in the movie but
should be a lot of fun so that's a big
deal so and then we're gonna be in
Argentina to an even payroll like doing
some stuff as well some Chester for like
exhibitions Cemal etc yes in January
I'll be playing in the in Guatemala and
in everywhere yeah I mean I'm there
after that I'll be playing in Gibraltar
this super strong tournament it's one of
my favorites like I think so Nakamura
was playing there eleven aronia actually
Levon Aronian beat me in last year I
mean he treated me so bad you know I I
mean I looked like a baby in that game
like a dog or a cat I don't know
now he could be in trouble because I got
the bishop / and then this vision when I
5 is extremely dangerous
also beef I brake is very very
interesting here and ok let's go for B 5
or maybe not because B 4 yeah let's go B
5 I'm not so sure B 5 before that's
where I'm worried about okay let's go B
5
he's offering me a draw come on we have
to play maybe you'll beat me but we have
to learn chess
take who's gonna take draws yeah
nobody's gonna take drawers here win or
lose exactly
Chaka Khan yes you can challenge make
sure you do it on chess 24 what's a link
in our chat this guy travels more than
yeah I mean this and so life of woody if
you want to be a G I'm traveling as
always go about travel everywhere play
tournaments yeah I mean before I was
less active because I mean I'm also
civil engineers so I was working as a
research at the University of Hamburg in
Germany and so I didn't have much time
but the last few years have been it's
been really really crazy okay so what
are we gonna do here I got so many ideas
maybe Queen f6 so he takes him d6 I was
planning to go Nana a3 which looks very
very beautiful
this moves sacrificing the pears to go
Queen f3 and then I think it's checkmate
either on g2 or h1 he goes Queen g5
Queen h1 and I think this is just a
checkmate Knight e3 I go Queen h1 so
he's got to resign here my friend gotta
give you a hand
good try try try I'm trying trying to
beat our GM who try and yeah this is
checkmate boom okay the commutator is
challenging again I don't know if it's
commentator a common commutator
commutator commutator what is this thing
like c4
okay let's go let's stick with to our
King team iam one of my favorite
openings you get unbalanced position
dynamic position and maybe he goes for
the main line exactly t4 occupying the
center now and I had a free shirt Castle
and I'm gonna play my pet line with
Bishop g4 he comes for Bishop d3 so
Bishop g4 definitely after Bishop e2 is
good so after Bishop d3 makes even more
sense because now they're gonna be a lot
of pressure on the t4 pawn I gave up my
bishop prayer but then d4 is weak it
goes D fire then I'll get the bishop
pair back
it goes Bishop III then Knight d7 and
then a lot of pressure on d4 finally we
will have to push to d5 and then I'll
get my beloved d4 square or a five
squared so are you from here from Sayle
sir I've been here a lot longer to be
from here okay yeah originally born in
China in China which would City so I
know some Chinese man trust me I can say
walk Cola oh no my best friend sir was
from China you're doing my masters in
Italy it was from Shanghai and then he
used to take me to teach me all this I
mean his name is was way young or
something like this very close to where
Yi mu we used to call him Juanito so my
friend money too
that's pretty impressive yeah and then
what else like I'm fully swore Paola
right oh no no no
well Paola no he cheated to me yeah so
how do you say I'm full
well pop close pretty close that was
close counting all right that what else
what can carne go can I see that
no all right I think I only know three
sentences that's that's impressive
I mean Danny in the back is always I'm
trying to learn Chinese he can say
anything and quite quite yeah is fast
right yeah
quite quite yeah nice nice you remember
I mean you know we have like once like I
was teaching then chess for one hour
some other guy was teaching how to play
the guitar and then my friend Juanito
was teaching some Chinese but this
happened just one day and I feel like
for somebody who doesn't use it on a
regular basis you still I still remember
something yeah yeah
yeah mine have a grandmaster okay
there's been an interesting game so far
so I got this born on d4 and then I want
to break here with b5 and then try to
create some sort of attack against the
disk in okay I'm gonna go h5 maybe he
goes for g4 and that's a blondie because
I got 95 and then Knight takes Bishop g5
interesting morph
I think mm-hmm 17 and radius 1702 okay
okay
f6 and b5 yeah let's go I have six here
he's got to go back and then I'm gonna
strike in the center but not in the
center on the Queen side with b5 pushing
the pawns yeah somebody said that pawn
on d4 so mean yeah and I've got two nice
squares c5 on c5 vote for my knight but
still he's got the bishop prayer and
then now Mike inside is actually pretty
weak after this f6 squared it's not I
mean I didn't want to go for this f6 but
okay yeah now b5 is coming o g4 are you
kidding me this is getting so crazy okay
okay if i takes on g5 this should be
good enough to win the game he wants to
take on h5 probably and then Knight e5
should be okay and commentator you have
a plan what's what's yes something
obviously okay I'm gonna go 95 just
winning a temple and then I'll decide if
I just take the pawn on g4 and nothing
happens oh I just take the bishop on
from G fine I think I'm gonna take this
Bishop from from g5 looks so tasty and
I'm hungry I didn't have lunch today
you know you have in this area there's
so many good restaurants oh yeah yeah
with it's like 2 bucks yes you know like
they're like in two blocks I like like
15 good restaurants like so did you try
the booter local here the Mexico
obviously tried every single
alright so I'm gonna close the position
with G for now so after H takes G 6 this
this Bishop could also come to 8 6 just
stop in 8 6 ideas from white side and
also I could try this B 5 move that I so
badly want to play now Bishop 8 6
nothing happens this King has to go to B
1 and then I'm taking this guy here and
C 4 give me that and after Bishop takes
I don't know I could do like rook b8
this sounds to me like a good move
so Bishop b3 and now maybe d3 is almost
winning the Queen it's got to go to d1
or f1 probably there's no other squares
it's at least I cannot see them and then
this is just too good for me a5 a4 ideas
win f6 targeting the B to pawn targeting
the f2 pawn and McInnis extremely safe
here by his own pawns right because he's
got no open files and life is great
commutator you can he push around man
yeah just around exactly
Queen d1 let's go clean up six Oh so
this guy says you speak a little bit of
Hindi yeah yeah because you know this
this program it was very international
so we were like in Italy for one
semester we were like 50 people from 30
different countries it was it's called
Erasmus Mundus Master program and then I
started two years in three countries I
was in Italy Germany and Poland and then
I had I was living actually with a guy
from Chennai his name is Alan but he is
not busy and he was actually be she's on
a neighbor in in Chennai so he used to
teach man song Hindi and also my
Nepalese friends you know my Nepalese
friends they also speak Hindi and it was
so much fun this program so I'm gonna go
now I wanna I go on a play group be to
here and then get crazy but I shouldn't
do rugby to Kintex beat you Knight c4
King b3 and Knight a5 King before that
should be checkmate I mean next e4 just
wins on the spot yeah but III just want
to go but I
I just want to go Ruby - so bad day okay
let's just be calm and then playing 94
and then be like a no behave like a
normal person and then take the B to
pawn and win the game so my guy said you
moved 95 much too late yeah I mean I was
actually waiting for for him to to fall
in this trick in this trap like g4 then
95 and then just the g4 point falls yeah
and I was also considering to go night
c5 in these kind of positions so that's
why I delayed it a little bit let me
tell you getting whooped commute ATAR
it's all good you're playing a
grandmaster in every I mean boom
give me that now it's got to resign rook
takes me to protects with to checkmate
checkmate you been to New York yeah many
times
I'm going there in two days Friday my
best friend's friend from Spain are
joining me for a week of of holidays so
what should i do there I mean man I mean
New York there's a lot of good
restaurants a lot of good I don't know
if you like like go see a play proper
Broadway yeah into that yeah and we're
staying actually in an Airbnb apartment
close to the Central Park so it sounds
like a good area okay
you feel like American football of
course yeah actually we're I mean NBA
didn't start yet so yeah that's a pity
if you wanted to do with some preseason
games I'm sure you could but yeah yeah
like for one week oh wow yeah yeah and
actually my brother is also coming so a
five now let's see what he does
cuz now you go be fighting I'm not gonna
play c5 in your whole life so that's why
rook big one was needed and now it's an
important moment should I go away five I
think she I should go if I
first I'm gonna get this a file open and
I'm gonna go f5 he could take text
Knight e5 but that doesn't work because
then I don't see trees hanging so
probably it's got to go to H 495 did I
just plot everything I blocked it from
am i blonder everything here all right
because 96 is coming oh my god this
guy's 2584 oh wow
yeah don't sound aliens so I should be
careful here I mean I'm losing for sure
in this position but then I have to find
something to trick him so oh wow I see I
saw made which is f 496 F takes Knight
68 context but there's Kim D - there so
should stop talking rubbish
okay I have to give up the exchange
seven and then all right let's play
matter fate and 96 and try to create
some counter play here in this position
of course I'm losing but you know it's a
blitz and anything can happen here so
neck takes Knight takes it takes this
pawn on c7 which looks also very very
interesting and now okay what should I
do here should I play
mmm-hmm man you are giving Pepe a hard
time yes yeah definitely so good good
yeah what's this guy saying done so just
upon down now not an exchange but of
course it was a really important point
on c7 now I'm planning to play not
afraid and try to survive in this
position probably I'm not gonna make it
sadly but I got some country play now
because f4 is coming if te Texan g7
group takes g7 f4 is gonna come here the
next move and then the bishop is
targeting a tree and definitely there
should be something here so I'm gonna go
f4 takes Queen d7 looks good looks good
27 he's got Queen d3 IDs over there I'm
not so sure
before could be a possibility to so pond
takes Queen T seven days Queen d3
incredibly in this position I cannot
believe this we need e3 e4 Queen a three
and looks good for four for white again
so how about if I just play Bishop f5
here developing a piece and then
intending to okay I'm attacking the rook
on b1 so it's got to go to B 2 or a 1
and then probably I could think of going
Knight g6 and some come to play in this
position because he can't take an e5 cuz
there is Queenie five and then I just
win the a piece on C Street so I'm gonna
take this pawn on f4 and now Queenie
five or even yeah Bishop f3 that's good
move
that's a good move man so I'm gonna play
Knight a5 or Knight age for both of them
looked good to me okay let me think for
a little bit okay I'm gonna play Knight
age four years so putting pressure on
the f3 [ __ ] I got 40 seconds get cake
can't think too much
yeah some natural moves exactly Bishop
f4 maybe is coming here yeah rook afraid
putting pressure on the f5 so Bishop g3
probably and I think White's better but
I have some ideas here so let's play
King h8 here so there's no check over
there so now 90
it's back attacking this Bishop Queen g5
let me go 94 here 94 why is that move so
takes takes I could even take this guy
now here in a 196 now I'm gonna go back
to man Bishop d7 15 seconds now the f4
bishop is hanging Sun blundering
everything here man Bishop f6 we have
six takes takes and and oh man I just
run through everything you can see this
rookie six and on scenario I do you yeah
I'll give you ten bucks to quit right
now every single thing here it happens
man
c'est la vie yes love II said I mean
good games on some dolly oh he's playing
too too slow he's got 30 seconds so no
no way that I will flack him okay good
game my man don't some valium
that's impressive yeah good job job okay
when I get some points back you're
choosing somebody so just let everybody
know what's happening here the same with
chess club the next couple of weeks so
this coming if you're in st. Louis come
playing on tournaments this coming
Saturday the 19th we have a Saturday
night special tournament and also the
very next day on Sunday the 20th Sunday
6 players Swiss both quick rate rated
and both usually have a really good
turnout so it's kind of a fun fun time
so come see that also we have big
tournaments coming up we have our Winter
Classic starting on November 9th that
would be broadcast that will be streamed
out on youtube channel as well then it's
Tralee straight after that we have the
st. Louis fall Invitational which is an
ornament starting on the 21st and that's
only the stuff that's happening here so
let's also not forget about all the
Grantchester stuff there is
London's starting up soon basically
right around Christmas I mean not
Christmas Thanksgiving sorry and then we
have rapid and blitz slightly before
that was that I mean nowadays like every
there's a chest stuff going on
everywhere in the world yeah so cool
it's definitely growing I love it I love
it
that's the goal all right so he played
the London system actually my last
lecture I'm planning to show you
something how to play against the London
system so he went for Bishop b2 here
it's not the most critical line because
you normally want to put this Bishop on
d3 where it's actually you know in a
more active square so now I want it
fight for the e5 square so I'm gonna
strike in the center with E 5 and
definitely this is a good position for
black so I got more space here and then
I got some potential attacking chances
on the kingside 2 with some h5h for
ideas now I'm just gonna go back to c7
probably and then bring the roots to the
center and the other rope to the e-file
all right yeah Cobra from Germany do you
see these you see anybody that's regular
it's as always challenged of course yeah
Cobra I played against him four times
him and blitz you can see here for
Zyliss crew so I know him pretty well
we've got people like being here in
chess twenty four four four four five
years for rating so how do you like
speaker was how do you like working for
chess learning for I mean I just love
this kind of job you know it's a lot of
fun I mean I'm working normally with one
of my best friends doing commentary with
the mid Martinez so I still it's like
we're watching chess I'm talking about
it so it's just so easy you have to work
in something fun for your job yeah
exactly how is this say like choose
something that you like and then you
won't have to
and you know their whole life you know
like yeah I mean okay
position is solid for him but we got
some space here and then this Bishop
could be I mean good attacking piece in
the future if I managed to play some d4
and then open this iron out and just
gonna improve my pieces step by step
maybe rookie 7 and then double rooks on
the e-file or the TV file I don't know
and then let's see what he does because
whenever he goes c4 then or efore this
bishop after some traits gonna get a
pretty active here so what your regular
against is copper guy it's four zero
it's worse video it's four zero yeah man
maybe today maybe today so you do it see
you do it
so rookie seven he's planning to go c4
probably but I'm not so sure about this
move because then all the end games I
will enjoy some three versus two and
then this vision is is going to be a
great piece okay so look d2 and now also
some 94 IDs I'm gonna go for this could
there could be some even Brooke III
ideas and then Queen takes g3 but okay
still this night and f3 is protecting
everything so now I'm gonna double ropes
on the e-file insisting on this theme
I'm sacrificing on on e3 so one of our
viewers was asking what do you think
about ICC ICC I used to play there like
a lot of time ago and then all these
rest of the rest of web chess website
started to to come and to appear and
then I'm not so active anymore on CD and
ICC but of course I spend a lot of time
as a child there so ever ever kasha so
we have a lot of kids that watch our
videos and come to the club and the
common the most common question they
have for grandmasters is like
what does it take to go from let's say
like I mean that's okay that's a really
tough question if I had the answer like
how to improve like a hundred times a
hundred hundred points every time I will
be michael thousand already but okay I
can say what what I did and basically
okay let me think first for a second in
this position I'm thinking Quincy five
looks good and it's very important to
play a lot of tournaments I mean you
could you can study and then you should
studies should study like reading books
and doing tactics but then if you don't
play this one helped because it's very
different like to study than playing
chess because you want in a tournament
you feel the pressure and then it's it's
very different so first of all you play
as many tournaments as you can I know in
some countries not that easy to find a
strong tournaments for example I was so
lucky because in Spain it's actually one
of the the countries that organized more
tournaments in the world and then for
example in summer you can play an
international tournament every week so
from June to October and then with
possibilities of I am an GM known so
it's it's easy to grow as a chess player
in Spain so even if you study like I was
going to college and stuff but then I
try to pass everything during the
regular course and then play a lot of
tournaments in in the summer so just do
some tactics studies on openings like
and then some results with will come for
sure
so you're saying like actually
tournament experience is key yeah yeah
yeah so you heard the kids play as many
terms as you can gain experience yes
that's great that Spain has such a big
like Cheska culture yeah yes and it's
growing a lot we can feel it in the in
the broadcast like a lot of people are
starting to follow chess broadcasts and
stuff like that and then also the
Spanish government approved like chess
is going to be in school really oh yeah
so yeah I I read about that from
like there they're putting chess in
schools I mean in Russia it's being
extremely popular like for ages and it's
a it's almost Nationals border your
chest also in Armenia for example with
Lebanon Aronian and stuff like that but
in Spain it was not like that but now
actually in writing an article about
chess as a power tool for education for
the st. Louis radio and I talked about
that there is a program in my region
like it's called a lava socket where
actually there is a counseling for chess
teachers and also courses for them to to
learn how to teach chess in school and
they didn't win against the Cobra
yeah we're gonna do you no good good
sportsmanship I'll give you a hand okay
I'm gonna play a friend of mine sorry
okay he lives in actually in Malaya it's
one Spanish city in the north of Africa
very small city and okay c49 of 6 so
this gentleman asking have you ever
played the world the real tin cup
Stockham actually no but they invited me
this year actually and but this autonomy
is normally in the last part of December
so my mom would kill me you know if I if
I run away from home during Christmas
you know it's like from 25 to 2nd of
January or something so it's not a good
time for me to to play a tournament but
I mean I played the the I'm I played the
Swedish Lake for a lot of years with a
team from lund and I'm actually playing
for loon still so but this this year
haven't played any game but yes I love
Sweden it's it's a really nice country
Cobras has good game ok thank you that's
500 down Cobra 5-0
ok now I'm planning to go Bishop f5 and
h5
this is some Kings Indian attack with
Robair scullers
right so let's see what happens I'll try
it
keep the position close in the center
and then attack on the on the keen side
it's around New Year that's why you know
so that's why I never played there and
stalk him but I've been visiting
Stockholm for a weekend with my friends
and it's a nice series a nice City how
many how many different kind of country
would you say you've been to now I think
I was doing the count not really my
father was doing this for me and then he
said like more than 35 or something so
so so I visited almost all countries in
Europe and then the most countries in
Latin America so still a lot to to get
to know in the nation and Africa for
example so youyou said that since so I
you had a lot of opportunities to play
chess in Spain just because it's in the
country like it's very popular yeah
so what do you do if that wasn't that
case for example like Grandmaster Cobian
was telling me a story about how he was
when he was growing up there was nothing
around him so he had to travel like yeah
six hours do something I mean it's it's
very different if you are a professional
chess player or if you're not because in
my case I was actually never a
professional chess player because I was
combining with my engineering stuff okay
so but I mean if you all want to play
professional chess of course you have to
travel you know you have to travel a lot
and I know I have some friends Latin
American friends they have this problem
in the countries because in Latin
America you can also you can only find
like let's say and I just blown their
place now so not so sure I can play five
min let's see mmm cuz what they do is
they normally travel to Europe to Spain
actually but then of course that's a lot
of money too so it's it's not easy as my
position now so I'm gonna take I'm gonna
play Knight b6 I think I saved the piece
no because Queen c6 Queen c8 I think
I've managed to save that piece I had a
really great position and then after
talking some [ __ ] then I blunted a
piece but now we're still in the game
it's just a pawn down all right viewers
I'm gonna do my best to distract you
guys yeah that's your job definitely
let's see this guy says have you moved
to st. Louis February no no no no no no
we are we we welcome him anytime he
wants to we welcome and yeah it's a nice
City but actually I'm living in in Spain
I mean if you can consider living in
some place like to be like in three days
in every place something like that at
the most but I live in Spain it's quite
nice over there without we got good
weather good food and bad positions like
mine now so let's see let's see ok I
have to go wow this is just terrible
position ok let's try to create some
counterplay 8 a 4 a 3 root K 5 here
Bishop c4 is coming this is just so bad
okay I'm gonna play Knight d7 and then
try to survive in this position I'm not
gonna make it guys a 396 wow man oh my
god come on you can do it
rookie should be 5 ok he didn't go for
this before
I'm completely losing of course I'm
completely doing just ugh it's because
your friend and you is coming I cannot
go even Kingi further it's made over
there and then it's time to resign it's
time to resign I'm gonna collect
everything oh my gosh I'll give you a
pre and entered handle that one good job
good job let's try to find some
stalemate tricks now if he goes rookie 5
ok I'm gonna meet him now give me that
give me that
ok do it
I see Spanish food it's got too many
points you know Spanish food really
tastes good
okay it's really good I want to I want
to try it man I want to have I want to
have no I want to borrow yeah yeah yeah
some tacos or quesadilla or whatever I'm
hungry now hungry we all checkmate you
didn't go for the checkmate what's going
on here oh so it looks like other
members of the st. Louis staff are
actually watching watching us checkmate
okay all right good job good job
I keep trying to get some points back so
now at some points let's play 2,400
kramnik student I think it bit me once
no it's just one zero for me so now it's
time to play some good chunk of chess
yeah he's been taught talking a lot on
the chat yeah yeah very well known here
we go here we go this is this laughs and
now we're gonna play here like Knight B
to d2 so the plan is to go b3 Bishop d2
Bishop d3 and then short Castle here and
maybe I could install a beautiful knight
on e5 he doesn't allow me he goes for a
5 straight away which is interesting now
I cannot take on d5 Custer's efore here
so hmm okay I'm first to take your knee
5 and now again let's take everything
here and sure Castle there is not a 3
nothing happens all right Black has
already a nice position here so I'm
gonna go 8 3 and then add a 3 Queen c2
and then connect my rooks Salah plan
solid plan before I think he blundered
he blundered already he plundered yeah
come on guys you see how to win this
position you see I'm not good enough he
asked me that stuff ok not a fancy is
people are rooting for your opponent
yeah and the crumbling student is loved
and chest went in first
so nada three has got to go to ecigs and
then 94 just wins a game so yes playing
in six and then 94 just wins
so probably is going to resign here
maybe he's trying to I mean if I didn't
resign in the previous game he's got to
play I mean I was playing like with
tampons down yeah how do you rate no no
I don't know crap mix to you then so
it's not my friend but we know from the
streams you know we know each other so
this gentleman is asking from one to ten
how do you rate the Cochran gambit I
would say one there you have it one out
of ten yeah so okay he went for this
language was the best by far so it's got
one rook and a piece for the Queen
so still surviving here chronic student
see here Chaka Khan where he have is
playing everybody it's just basically
who's who who chooses the way ran
randomly yeah yeah it's okay you can
challenge me yeah get your challenge in
well we can probably we'll get to you
yeah for sure
yes crime next student is love indeed
around here
got it as much as fairies hey oh come on
yeah Mick Mick trolleys why no it's also
one of the legends in just 44 will be to
pressure and b7 what are you gonna do
now
gromek student you're gonna go root beer
and play passive [ __ ] I'm 86 okay fair
enough
now I'm gonna go 90 for this night this
square is fantastic photo for my night
there are some tricks here I could try
Queen a3 so to see if he blunders knight
c6 and the next move
it's not easy though to protect this c6
pawn now cuz Knight e4 alright so you
what are you going with this night I'm
gonna go f3 here so after night g3 King
f2 or even just Knight takes c6 looks
also good enough you
for white some point just have to be
sure that there's no made after Nexus 6
truck t1 stuff like that waste these
night going where are you going my man
after Queen before I think your night is
trapped so maxi for route XE perhaps
just wins you know that was a joke
I know me I know me there's love in the
air yeah rook takes Queen takes this is
just a piece for free so it's a matter
of technique now which I don't have but
we'll try King f2 maybe g4 at some point
I'm Adam maybe that's too much and
probably I will go Queen be free to put
pressure on b7 I just blundered the c5
font but okay he didn't see is see that
sorry so Queen B to now of course
there's from discard mobs so probably
he's got to go to 87 and then I'm gonna
play Queen c3 and then at some point
start improving my position on the keen
side I would say f4 maybe King f3 and or
even King g3 Knight f3 stuff like that
sounds good sounds good okay let me go
King g3 Kramnik c9 you're not doing too
well
[Music]
alright so rookie 7 I'm gonna go native
3 no so aiming to go Knight g5 here I'm
probably Queen f6 Queen f6 also a nice
ad here also
efore could be I try here because of the
rook takes Knight g5 is coming I mean
this is completely waning right so 95
now he's first to take a d5 give me that
and he resigns alright
good try good try 3 points I try what is
this ok let's play soon said big
disaster
I mean he he played quite well the
opening but then he just blundered this
this piece on fr everybody has an off
day it's ok yeah hi King Pepe hey so you
know there was a time like like 2 years
ago I reached like 25:41 so
I was in one of my best moments but then
so the Olympic team I just needed like
20 more points or something like that to
get into the Olympic team but then I
started to play like like a baby again
so for example I couldn't win a single
game against 2200 players in like in six
months you know okay III went down 60
points and it was a disaster it's a
disaster you know so I'm gonna go like
b5 attack of course this Queen f6 not
them the main move 21 Bishop c5 okay
once go for the checkmate
not gonna happen now so Queen d2
protecting f2 and allottee what do you
do against this c7 guy I like that I
like the bold going for checkmate that's
yeah that's good your basics
now I'm gonna develop this guy to c3 and
tend to go 95 prolly 97 is best move
here and then probably Queen f4 alright
so that should be bad move so 95 Queen
takes Queen to X now this should be
rubbish for him so maybe he can go Queen
ePHI but worst case I can always go back
to c3 this Bishop on b6 is also hanging
so this looks already very very bad for
black that's right you don't Harbor
black yeah so I think tomorrow we are
doing some blindfold event here yeah I
think I think that's a plan Danny can
you confirm that yeah so now I I don't
know I don't know we can think of so
we're running name yeah we are looking
so viewers we are looking for a name for
our show tomorrow Perry's gonna complain
some place in my blindfold chess so if
you have any ideas of what to call the
show yeah it's gonna be a real bore I
guess against some opponents here yep we
have some opponents lined up for you
that's gonna be fun
she's gonna play to me if I'm like if
I'm if you I'm the last person so that
it's really needed I will but don't
Danny don't say that Danny just said
they might name me so they have two
people lined up already
they're ready to go ready to go we need
some more people about it's just can I
use my phone and pull pull engine and
play how about the Denny's Jamie is
crazy
I've got a lot of people that want to
play so I'm probably way down a list
their way down so anyways you have a
good name for a show blind chess will
prep a chat us and we'll we'll take into
advisement you know how good is the
Vienna gambit it's it's really
interesting I mean there's a for example
Django Stefan has some video series
about that in another web page and I
mean it's a played a lot in in top chess
so d4 d5 c-46 not a three-night of six
Knight c3 D takes e4 that's a vienna and
it's very very very interesting as my
position here so let me just play a six
boom check you gotta go backwards you're
gonna play f6 probably otherwise woohoo
give me that and then this bishop is
also coming to the action there is a big
party here in c4 salsa party but chatter
body you should see for him then he's
got to resign probably looks terrible
for black already yeah nothing to a
unified and queen eight six so it looks
like creme extreme said what paper plate
is from hammers repertoire right I don't
know I didn't know about this but
probably hammer is a really good player
for Norway like hey I think it was one
of the seconds from Magnus Carlsen
if I am
not wrong maybe not maybe just saying
something stupid probably not so all the
viewers on our YouTube chat
you see danny mccooz just said GM Marian
Petrov is making a course on the V in
the gamma so if you interested look it
up look it up but Rach what number are
you or not taking we're not taking a
list of who plays who plays for Pepe
next so you just challenge him on chess
24 and hopefully we will get to you at
some point
all right checkmate and see the next
Challenger how good how good is that
Blackmar d my writer gambit yeah not my
favorite one I mean there are some
gambits that are played in top two and
top top chairs
McQueen's can be this my favorite let's
play you 2,500 player now gonna [ __ ]
deciding exciting okay let's play
neither three here just lower 75 I'm
gonna try my best to distract Pepe so
you know yeah get your win in you can
ask you about Spanish food and stuff for
now let me ask you this so it says let's
in preparation for tomorrow's blindfold
how often do you play my phone not much
actually I should play often but I used
to do it with when I was training with
the Spanish Federation like when I was
16 18 they they first has to play blind
fully and it's really important I mean
you actually learn a lot and then you
you improve a lot your calculation
skills and what at what level do you
recommend people like to start trying to
do that just to like kids I mean you can
start even when you're a beginner and
you will realize that you cannot see
even two mobs but then you will start
improving so then at some point you will
be able to to play a whole game and that
you will feel real really happy me I
want to say I never really seen anybody
under
probably a 1,600 play of life I don't
know they can yeah it's tough it's tough
for sure okay so he wants to go see
five-year can I please see five myself I
know it I mean it's typical in this kind
of positions because okay you got the
deep-fry square but I got your bishop
now b7 is locked so you're not opening
this I am gonna in the rest of the game
and then I got this nice ePHI square and
which I'm gonna use it now this night
could come also to c4 intend to go to g6
at some point so it's a double its
position two questions for you one
what's your over the border a rating now
OTB radium what is this over the board
so classic so I got like 25 23 okay 23
yeah that's my good another one a person
is wondering what's the point of Queen
c2 in the Catalan well Queen c2 not only
protects c4 which is one of the ideas of
course but then you want a strike in the
center with efore that's why the Queen
from c2 covers the e4 square then after
Knight B to d2 you are ready to strike
in that Center alright so how about this
move Bishop d2 in order to play b4
reinforce e5 and finally get this nag to
the c-4 square it doesn't allow me bad
guy so I'm gonna play h4 here in order
to go h5 for them probably it's going
Queen c7 in this position and then I
don't I cannot play Knight C forecast
Bishop c5 I just planted that phone I
think but series around equal here I
could also maybe look AC one was play it
was a better more because of the Queen
c7 I could meet that with a queen efore
centralizing my queen because now after
Queen c7 I don't find a nice square for
my knight probably I just have to go
back to f3 because if I go to d3 then
Bishop a is six the bishop is quite nice
over there actually goes for this Bishop
a6
and now I'm gonna go maybe Bishop b4 is
actually interesting f5 could be his
idea so I'm going to play rook a c1
again my idea after okay he just bonded
upon an 85 in it and I didn't see it
yeah so that's blitz for you yeah 575 we
are we're taking both three-minute
five-minute games no more than five
exact me to do some more question who is
the highest rated player you ever beat
an actual tournament okay let me think
what his rating at the time okay let me
think I saw I beat boy Kasich he was
twenty six seventy at that time I bet
Latin Iike we should check player with
26 something to you and who else who
else wait one sec okay gonna go 94 after
a five night at five so I never beaten I
think at 2700 I I made a draw against a
son of then I I made a draw against for
example Adams in Gibraltar Jones Gawain
and these guys okay just one second I
don't want to lose this game a 347
seconds okay should focus focus pepper
night c4 so Bishop c5 95 that was my
idea but Bishop F treated me didn't tell
me the move f5 okay give me that poem
Queen takes a five now Knight takes not
the opponent see a circus hanging so
it's got to protect it now Bishop a5
attacking this route you gotta go to ca
to e8 and now I'm taking this guy here
and then Bishop takes d5 just winning
the game rook takes d5 at least two
points now rookie two
interesting move so I'm gonna go bishops
III here rook c5 probably is a good move
now rooks he finds a good move he
doesn't go for deer so I'm gonna collect
this guy here with a check rook a five
and now rook f3 probably or even g4 Ruka
3 sorry looks good to me
now you can take and c5 because there is
Bishop f6 but I only got 20 seconds
salty 1 exactly at the same time left
then whatever you're saying they'd love
your commentary because it's like you're
in this yeah that's why why we love okay
that's why we want him to move here any
time you want to move st. Louis we're
ready for you okay come on take the
opponent be tube then the a pawn are you
totally this is gonna hump look at that
time trouble
come on him for him yep yep alright
trying that one whoa we were talking
about something oh yeah the
highest-rated few oh yeah yeah
what do you think about the Evans King
damn it
Evans gambit okay it's nowadays is
difficult to surprise your opponents so
it's a good try to surprise your
opponent but the bad news is if your
opponent knows how to face it probably
you'll end up with a bad position so
20:26 off now I'm gonna play my favorite
opening the Philidor so this line with E
5 here 93 Knight B to d7 and route g1 oh
it's going for it it's going for it now
I will have to react in the center I
think I played this game already against
the Alcina
one run myself or anything I went crazy
here with this d5 reaction and I'm not
sure if it was here
we should be for Queen e2 Knight b6
looks looks interesting so just trying
to get this pawn back on d5 and Bishop
b5 check just Bishop d7 and they studies
to protect this d5 pawn just gonna grab
it in the next move and then Knight a5
okay fair enough
I'm gonna go a long castle here just see
if his let's see if he takes this pawn
g7 just talking about you being the
famous banter blitz
alright so interesting position little
bit crazy let's see what happens he can
take this pawn on g7 but then I will
have definitely a lot of contra play
because his skin is still an e1 my next
move is g6 you know we call the f1 we
call it Facundo and in Spanish that's
why everybody's first contest is talking
about Facundo cramming soon just regain
this points he lost to you today Wow
play somebody else okay
ah all right so I'm gonna promote that
sexy setup so everybody you have about
20 minutes left so get your challenges
in a chest 24 while you can okay because
tomorrow we're not playing the people
were playing blindfold chests so get you
burns in now okay time to grab the spawn
or not no I'm just blundering because
Knight takes Knight takes Knight takes
Queen takes and then 97 so we gotta be
really really careful here maybe should
be for was a better move here
Knight takes Queen takes rook e3 and
then Queen c5 and for sure we have
something here I think his skin is in a
really bad position on anyone and
we'll see weenie seven now here's got a
plate rook III and I got different
options here I can go Quincy five which
looks good enough to me a cust now we're
getting this pawn on d5 and then once
that is done black will be definitely
better here because this game is only
one jet Wow you know from Israel
DQ now time to wrap a poem finally now
time to check with the night here Ruki -
[Music]
looks like the opponent is in time
trouble
yeah and position is not so good - King
F one question is are we gonna have Pepe
covering any tournaments in the future
we probably will we get I mean probably
big big tournaments we have commentators
come in so and we'd love Pepe so of
course we're definitely gonna have him
in the future we'd love to yeah so can I
grab this vote on g4 I think so because
after Luke takes AI just queen a tree or
queen D one intermediate moves so this
is good enough for black here what's
your favorite chess book okay if I have
to choose one I would choose
I think it's called the seven chess
scenes in chess
it's from Jonathan Rosen is a British
scrum master he's also he's also a
philosopher I think his writing skills
are very very good that I would say is
my favorite book alright so now okay
yeah I think we're doing fine here
so 94 Bishop f4 still bothers me a
little bit okay let's let's play fast
let's play fast 94 and Bishop f4
probably let's play Queen f5 here
bringing the pieces back a little bit I
got 42 seconds so I should be fast here
and
by 10 seconds yeah you got thank you
Queen keep ice we should take screen
takes 25 Wow
all right give me that give me that and
94 now to stop d6 this is a good
position this is a good endgame King d7
I'm gonna play b6 and rookie 5 now first
thing him to take on g6 and the pawn on
d5 now it's very very weak so I'm gonna
take it now I'm gonna take that give me
that
now 94 check it's got to go to back and
then see 585 king c6 rook define I'm
gonna promote every single move and then
here we say alright viewers so if you're
interested in looking for Pappy's
favorite books
send me doing these sins Danny Machuca
has graciously put that on our chest so
you can just click the link what are the
seven deadly sins so if you're talking
about chest it's that book if you're
talking about what the actual 70
identity since our look it up look it up
Danny one of the seven I said you got
wrath greed yeah Royals like money
pride all right we're gonna stop right
there all right Pepe what sloth there we
go there we go
Kevin is the Dutch of valid line valid
line and play where should we focus more
popular opening like the Kings Indian or
just a Chobani line to pleasure they
focus more like you can see in the urn
just I mean the Dutch is perfectly
playable I mean everything is playable
maybe not in the India leat but for the
normal human beings as we are everything
is more than playable so of course go
ahead and check the Dutch I mean my
family is the key Indian but the Duchess
is definitely playable so we are not
getting these tiny tiny advantages where
the top GM's
move yeah all right have you ever read
the book called logical chess move by
move no no this person asked if you
would recommend this so you haven't read
it yet why don't you go ahead and read
it first let us know how it is and if
you recommend it will let people know
mmm yeah so Danny my chick in the back
has also put in if you want to learn the
Dutch gin gee-gee and has a new course
on chesil so you can check that out cams
575 see how you like it
yeah he's so funny yeah I really like
ginger Jim we want to try that in the
future try to invite all these guys in
here will be also a pretty pretty fun
wave on
alright alright sending portal moment
you have about 15 minutes to get your
challenge into GM FA because after that
we are off so get your challenges in and
why you can okay know what guarantee
season I play you because we have a long
list but which buy our best okay think
now black is fine but nothing special so
Queen takes rook takes and then there's
always this f5 move that he has to pay
attention to because the bishop could be
trap at some point and in this vision
from f3 is also pointed out to be 7 what
do you recommend against the g3 English
which is basically the Hedgehog well you
can play with a 5 this is what every top
Grandmaster place nowadays against e4 e5
and then those systems are considered to
be ok for black you're going to play you
can also go for the can scindia maybe
that's not what you prefer and I got to
play fast again I'm gonna go for this f5
move f5 360 for sure so I'm gonna go
roopd 1
I'm also threatening now to go a v e5
cuz this night could be in trouble
this night from d7 so Knight b6 in moves
and then route before intending to go
for this b7 point Brian Knight c4 is a
good move rook d7 rook b8 then he's
gonna get a lot of country play on the B
file but I think we're doing fine here
night c4 rugby 7 rupee egg text xb3
Mario 3 look detune position is around
equal and Knight d7 back so I'm gonna
take this pawn here on b7 and okay and
check out sometime
yeah and now and now I'm gonna play b3
rook c8 group d3 was my idea night c5
rookie 3 so I think we managed to
protect everything in this position and
now it's time to bring the King to g2 to
protect c2 and c3 and then we should be
much better here so King f2 King a 1
let's play a 4 a 4 which gives us
another night square
on b5 night before king d2 and then
still not ready to move the knight on c3
because then c2 is hanging so that's why
bishop d1 here looks like a really
passive move but the idea is we've gone
95 c3 kick this night and then play 94
okay let's go 94 attacking this Bishop
now
f5 is in the air now f5 is in the air
let's go for f5 he's gonna take this
pawn there's no other choice for him and
then Bishop d5 saves the piece for him
but then we are doing fine here
40 seconds yeah Knight b5 here i
blundered upon a g-tube tough life 53 I
just blunder 94 Forks so we've gotta be
really careful here let's play Bishop c4
here and tell you to capture this pawn
on f7 so it goes a 6 and gonna take and
then play group d3 no I'll just play the
94 Oh didn't see it didn't see it
alright so now we should be doing fine
and again 94 then alright alright
alright the King III probably is going
to g6 now with this vision then okay
give me that look for free I love Brooks
for free
alright give me a hand for that one try
good try
alright so what our views is asking what
is do you think Carlsen
how is Carson doing in the grand Swiss
do you think Caruana is better than
Carlson has moments no I think Gaussian
is the best player by far so writing is
actually pretty I mean I mean there's
770 different point difference yeah
seventy points gap between them so I
would say Carlson is a much stronger
player I mean not much stronger but the
ground tree is say it looked like Cal
said they start pretty well because he
made like three draws in a row I think
but now he managed to
win two games in a row and a game
against Ganguly is actually nice in
particular and then I want to check that
game in my last lecture here so on
Thursday actually tomorrow we'll cover
that game in our grandmaster choice
lecture so we'll analyze deeply that
game against Ganguly because actually it
was a very important game for him
because he managed to get me I'll stop
95 straight without being beaten so if
you're interested in looking at game
join us for that class I should be on
stream as well it'll be a fun time from
our viewers out there we are look oh oh
the computer switched on no no it's back
do we disconnect it can you is that us
but the stream is out or still on ok is
connected so I should refresh maybe then
the page I mean we didn't I got 30
seconds so I should be yeah now we are
back I'm maybe it's me with my food I
disconnected the game ok we're fine now
yes ok ok
yes your boy Anton David yeah exactly
yeah and tomorrow he's facing me to gawp
so I'm so much looking forward to see
that game he says Carlsen Khurana
and England retinas are the strongest
players right now mm-hmm
don't forget like stream don't forget to
like the stream if you liked it thumbs
up for football style play-by-play that
is why everybody loves Pepe alright for
our viewers out there we are constantly
trying to different trying to do
different things to see what works and
what doesn't sort of like if you like
play the people would let us know if you
don't if you wanted to see something
else let us know also right now on the
chat says info icing those chest pop
org for any suggestions please email
that address and we were taken under
advisement I don't have any power to
change anything I can do this take it up
up to the boss see if he wants to do it
if he does we'll try it out we usually
like to try anything new once so if you
want to see something please let us know
that's a key yeah we're doing your stuff
yeah yeah you try you have to try new
things
not trying new things one of my that's
that's kind of what I live by always try
something at least once I think I even
tried to do some video mixing table
tennis and chess international master so
we play like four sets and then we
played like four games or something okay
I'm gonna take this guy here and we were
thinking about doing a combining chess I
want in like in sports and like some
sports that's a lot of fun or a combined
in chess and then I'm like cooking
cooking show oh really okay I don't know
if we can do that I don't know if we can
do that oh man if I if you make me cook
in you know I will destroy your plan I
will burn everything yeah we're like
thinking about doing like bringing
bringing some animals in yeah that's dog
see if that works
okay Danny Miceli has a whole list of
stuff you wanna bring a tiger okay you
couldn't take on e6 because of the King
h8 then he has to move the Queen and
then Bishop e6 and then rook e8
was win all right so this is like an
equal position I'm gonna go Queen a for
this is a very typical year to put
pressure and see - it's not easy for
black - for white now to protect that
pawn so it's got to sacrifice it and
then Queen c2 - just pawn up but then of
course it's got the bishop and then it's
pretty tricky so let's see where this
Bishop goes yeah for a second time
trouble all right Queen III so now I
think it's time to bring this key into
the corner so B should be six again
that's it doesn't work because of rook
e8 pin in this Bishop and
yeah my intention now is to go Bishop
teen salmon communicate the rooks bring
the rook to the center and life is
awesome so Queen a4 I really not scared
of
why don't you play only you play not
radio games okay yeah we only play radio
games yeah I just write again I just
want to lose all my points man that's
why all my points for Bishop d7 probably
is trying to go for Bishop fh5 but then
look f5 looks pretty strong eight four
oh it's going for it it's going for it
and then I should be careful in this
position I'm gonna go rook f6 broke at
six
all right see we have some new viewers
joining in all right how's it going
everyone there's only about less than 10
minutes left so probably after this
probably go one more game and then we
okay stop so let's see who the last
games gonna be well well you have one
second oh yeah he managed to make the
last move okay okay okay I'm gonna play
93 right come on stop at there thanks
for the game got it Williams from one
hand for you good job good job good try
good try and that's game right so let's
play the strongest opponent in the list
just to finish losing in a proper way
okay Arthur laughs this is the three
plus two okay let's play one three plus
two way no and the C on the g3 English
topic the guy was talking about earlier
I look at Grandmaster repertoire books
from hi I'm Aaron who takes look from
white side but it also seems that it's
not enough to equalize Wow you mean the
e5 lines
I mean if Carson plays it all the time
car 1 and so it should be good yeah and
this e 5 line almost everything
equalizes nowadays so at what time will
you be streaming your for analysis and
on what social networks I time and again
say you mean the Ganguly and Carlsen
tomorrow here from this channel
yeah look up look just stay on our go on
our YouTube channel signals Chess Club
tomorrow what is that six it's uh have
no what is that sixth Eddy right 6:30
local time so tune into our network then
you will see the full analysis of the
game and maybe you'll learn something
yes okay let me grab another last
opponent so let's grab let's take the
bull
22:41 oh so the casting on the g3
English topic he prefers the King's
Indian
mmm I'm not sure yeah what he means
alright 8hp and a whole bunch of other
and then numbers after that clarify and
we're trying to get to you before we
leave so I'm gonna play Bishop d3 and
this is not that main move of course but
it's it's actually pretty pretty
interesting so a tree is not already
considered to be the critical line so
now the idea is to put the bishop here
on the f3 squared and it's actually a
nice curve for the bishop because you're
putting some pressure on this diagonal
and now we're gonna go Bishop III Queen
d2 maybe even the long castle here why
not let's call on castle here and then
get crazy in the last game g4 h 4 g5
boom checkmate 'if i probably is gonna
be his move and now why not to play h4
let's go 8-4 could be also Knight g3
very interesting to jump this Knight to
f5 here so context e4 Quint x d4 looks
alright for black Bishop e5 Queen t2 and
then I just wanna I just wanted to go
Knight f5 here of course he isn't trying
to go Knight b6 or something like this
but then we can continue attack with g5
maybe or even at five within the bishop
pair so let's go back to d2 and now
probably Knight b6 or not f8 stopping
Knight f5 ideas because he D allows me
to jump to f5
then something bad is gonna happen on 86
okay 95 now and then all right so can I
go G 5 here H 4 takes no I'm gonna go
rookie 1 here so looking with x-rays to
this game very quick on e 7th and now
Bishop d4 could be afraid and let's see
what he does because he is got to put an
eye on on this c5 Knight it's attacked
by this bishop from e3 it's not that
easy
wow this guy is really getting into the
Kings gambit okay so Kings gambit King
junior change sorry Kings Indian I'm not
sure if it is equalizing theory yeah I
mean they're in Tupper detectives'
planner another pawn oh man I don't see
anything today so Bishop takes and then
Knight f5 okay let's go are you playing
inaudible Kings Indian is is it's it's
tough to play and against strong
grandmasters then probably they'll find
a way to get some advantage yeah but I
mean in our levels I mean as a human
beings non machines like Magnus Carlsen
it's really interesting opening so
sometimes again I get some students like
they are 10 years old and then their
parents come to me and say you know what
I don't want my son to play the dragon
because it's not playable and even see
you know what like your son is 10 years
like everything can happen with every
opening and most of them are playable
definitely many people are so obsessed
with this opening study and I mean I can
yeah a lot of a lot of people just seem
to think that opening is is the only
thing it's not played Kings India in top
level for a reason I agree I agree but
we are not in the top level right so
it's perfectly playable
so we do have a request for you to go
all right okay I'm gonna take this guy
here in d1 and then night at six
actually a big threat and all right 986
King 87 still not winning so gonna take
this guy in here
Mookie eight and then probably I'm gonna
take here with the check and then queen
eight five that's my idea because the
bishop on e5 is hanging oh man this is
just any ball or not I'm not so sure so
what happens team eight seven Queen h5
takes King f5 that's a key otherwise if
I take straight away on me fight this
night be three fork so it's good to move
the King I don't know why he is waiting
so much time because now okay now I'm
gonna play Queen h5 and then probably g6
that's that comes with a check so it's
got to resign cus after Queen g7 all
right down there is a fork now maybe it
doesn't need to resign
I don't know maybe keen seat or team B 1
let's play team B 1 so it takes the
knight on f6 then I'll drop this night
from c5 so it's got to play probably
Queen 93 then Queen f6 that looks that
like a good move because the rook on the
end it's hanging so he should take this
came with this knife with a kid but then
Brooke g4 a rook g3 looks completely
winning okay he goes back he plays rook
d7 and now Knight g4 this just a piece
up for me then Queen h4 is coming then
gonna collect this rook d3 and then this
knight is pinned so he's got to go back
to g5 and then this just piece up for us
and then we're gonna win this game 10
seconds for him King f3 a tree let's
play E for pre-move give me that baby 92
93 check let's play whatever 92 and he
took that okay and I'm gonna take the
pawn the ball go try the tribal yeah try
check
check check check check check check e
all right all right that is our last
game as we are out of time so viewers
tomorrow join in for blindfold chess
with Peppa cuenca and some staff of the
same with chess club it'll be a fun time
3 p.m. local time YouTube channel so
it's if you have any questions at all
when these suggestions info a st. Louis
chess club org yeah this man a lot of
fun and yeah hope you hope to see you
all tomorrow in this blind Philemon bad
guys have a nice day
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you